okay so um many of you have asked me
to talk about this i've gotten dozens of
emails a handful of voicemails a bunch
of messages during live streams saying
david you really need to investigate and
talk about some of the claims that are
being made by members of congress and
their staff
that some aspect of the trump riots
suggests some kind of inside job or
coordination either with members of
congress or
um it with with law enforcement and i
think it's very important
it would be irresponsible for for me not
to say that at this point what we have
is a set of allegations
many of which are still being
investigated and sort of nebulous but
this has come to a level where we should
talk about it so there's a few different
things going on here
first of all there have been concerning
patterns of posts and communications
involving some
right-wing members of congress in
particular new congresswoman
lauren bobert and it sort of exceeds the
scope of this
segment to go through the minutia piece
by piece but you can easily google this
and sort of explore
this path yourself where uh she
appears to have been communicating and
putting out
information that could just be
sort of generally supportive of the idea
of of a big protest which is what donald
trump is claiming he did but it ended up
inciting a riot
or maybe based on her being pictured
with some
individuals that seem to be riot folks
maybe she was in some way connected or
involved and there are sort of a number
of allegations along that front
there is also the very disturbing
allegation that has come
from a capitol hill staffer that
office panic buttons were removed
in advance of the pro-trump riotous
insurrection her name is sarah grow
she's the chief of staff of democratic
congresswoman
presley and she said that she along with
others
were taking refuge in ayana presley's
office as protesters
and rioters flooded in and that
they barricaded the door with furniture
and they were in there and then they
looked for the panic buttons
and the panic buttons were gone uh
saying every panic button in my office
had been torn out
and saying they could not find any
rationale as to why that
took place saying they've used them
before that they had not switched
offices and that there were panic
buttons
in that office which were subsequently
gone um
what is the explanation for that we
don't know we we simply don't know at
this point
in time it's being investigated and it
should be investigated
we also heard from congressman james
clyburn and james klein
clyburn explained and i'm going to play
a clip for you momentarily
that he has a marked office
at the capitol which says congressman
james clyburn that's
that's his marked office but that as
majority whip
he uh tends to work at an unmarked
office in a different part of the
building
and that somehow the riders knew exactly
where to go even though it was an
unmarked office
this is him explaining it take a listen
to this the next part of this
which is what makes this even more
troubling with what you were sharing
with our folks this morning
part two of this of what you were
reporting about is talk about the damage
to your offices you have two different
offices in the capitol explain it to our
viewers
well i have an office in the capitol uh
which is in
the so-called lincoln room named after
abraham lincoln
that office has my name on the door
and it has majority whip above the door
and it's just off of statuary hall
anybody walking through statutory hall
can see that office
now that's not where i do most of my
work
up on the third floor is where i do most
of my work and there are many members
of the united states congress right now
who could not tell you where that office
is
and could not find that office if they
needed to
yeah i i've been there it's hard to find
sir i agree
it is not easy yes yeah but they found
it
nobody touched the door uh where my name
is but they were on the floor and my
staff is inside my inner
office with furniture piled at the door
with people trying to get in that did
not let them
in my question is how did they know
where that office was that to me
needs a thorough investigation and i do
believe
uh that for some sensitivities here
there were people uh taking uh
selfish uh with these
insurrectionists something's wrong here
right
so again very troubling allegations the
explanation
for which you know individually any of
these
stories might have some explanation
that's relatively benign
i've not heard it yet and so i i want to
be
again as i've said before an unending
unsatisfiable endless
uh gets us into conspiracy theory
territory we're both evidence for
and lack of evidence and evidence
against all is all as evidence for the
conspiracy
i'm not going to fall into that at this
point i've seen
enough that says to me
i am not understanding why these
different things
took place if indeed they took place as
they are being alleged and it certainly
needs to be investigated and we've
since learned uh about a number of
different
officers involved with the capitol
police capitol police officers who have
been suspended
and uh are being investigated for their
roles and
we already know it's not within the
realm we beyond the realm
of reality that capitol police
uh acted at least some people
incorrectly
during this and it must be investigated
how far this goes i i think that that's
roughly and i know that
many of you wish i could be more
definitive about this that's basically
my thought about it at this point in
time the allegations are troubling and
if they are true or even part of them
are true
there's quite a bit of explaining that
needs to be done we will continue
following it
this episode is sponsored by bluechew
one of the things i make a priority
on the show is not to perpetuate stigma
for things that don't deserve it we've
talked about mental health we've talked
about many things where we should all
just be respectful adults period and we
would be better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable blue chew is
prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the usa and since blue
chew prepares and ships direct it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
and best of all no more awkwardness
we've got a special deal for our viewers
and listeners go to bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pay just five dollars shipping that's
blue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechew is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show